yeah you know what welcome to this video
playing epic effects so is he going to
do
I got a king zinnia it's generally good
news I'm scoring quite well with the
children even though I don't know it all
that well but still probably better than
most important's okay so g5 and so on is
a threat I hope to address that yeah
this is this funny line where black gets
submission into e3 and it's not clear
that really Nets all that much but how
do I play and something with Queen c2 I
believe is right Queen c2 b2 I think you
go here I don't I don't quite remember
but I mean I'm just playing this
variation I don't I have not studied it
all that much when I can go at five here
and it is not well placed on these three
really because I want to take and yeah
this is not the bishop is wrong on d3
because f4 is a move that I generally
want to make and that's not good
how do I play this how do I play this
position at four I mean I'm not sure
about this move
okay I need to play in something to not
get into time time trouble that easily
I'm not sure about this move generally
you don't want to do it the bishop is
pretty good on h4 but Bishop d3 are
already I'm screwed this up a little bit
and maybe this to speed up the whole
thing a little bit I know I'm getting
his light into play but it is done it
coordinates my position I love it
okay so I would just say go here and
then play for F form okay so I can just
play a 402 do it so clean h3 to attack
the pawn I don't know but this is a
central square nice would be to get in
back Knight f1 III okay is he
threatening to check maybe
right g3
that's uncomfortable Willie let's get
out of the chick a plenty see 590 43 is
try and look G fall I guess but I can 93
look at 4 and maybe you can can really
do that one stick double
fg2 protectors so it's not like he's got
an easy way of playing he have it I'd
seen see an easy way for him to kill me
it looks a bit shaky really
I am this is kind of what probably is
the critical thing Queen age for okay so
really so I'm just take it take it down
but what is the threat what is the
threat Queen age for I don't I don't see
it lets see it
maybe that's a perpetual it's okay yeah
cannot have it all
[Music]
time warning what nonsense he's got to
check there I mean what am I doing here
ah yeah I wouldn't unnecessary loss
earlier I wasn't there was a position
where nothing happened really I think
okay I can still try to fight a little
bit but it's of course objectively lost
[Music]
God what an unnecessary game really
Queen dee four wins
I'm completely overloaded Jam check
and that's a lot I really really hate
them right
I think I mean I don't know maybe I'm a
petroleum it I don't believe it
so okay night in fall as possible and
that really it really works yet it does
work here yeah I only saw that it loses
right before I do only here yeah okay I
didn't didn't play the opening well and
it was kind of uncoordinated but so it
looks reasonably safe but it's probably
almost impossible to do much there yeah
I can take on fYI it's something that I
consider pre flavored I didn't see this
idea only Queen takes inform then it's
actually very good form on it and it
looks very good yeah okay but there will
always be some some more chances now I
played the opening not well yeah Bishop
sorry bishop T three years I think
probably probably wrong that the timing
of this move is wrong form to counter f5
I want to wear force actually good here
why can I sell sacrifice I can actually
sacrifice them
so then f4 was good I didn't see this
idea this came in and I'm attacking with
all pieces huh no I didn't see this idea
at all that that is a
it is a completely winning position so I
have f4 here hmm I didn't consider the
piece sacrifice it makes f5 really a bad
move this disabled okay and like it's
happy about the trades but I wanted to
get some coordination check your jump
probably lost Oh check check check check
check
welcome to nothing to do here we only
understood very late and at this age
towards winning okay thanks for watching